I hated them when it was going well.
I hate when I can have a chippy for like a love triangle.
But now everything seems easier,
I just need a regular day instead of a Friday to work.
Patience is factor regardless.
For a good day there is always somebody all worked hard on it.
Your day makes all the difference and that's the most important part.
So busy and stressed out.
If I was doing things at home, I was suddenly quite stressed out.
Good evening and welcome.
My name is Kat, my pronouns are she and her.
And we are so glad that you're here,
whether this is your first time or your first time in a long time.
We are so glad that you chose to be with us on this cold holiday weekend.
Since our rental situation,
kind of for Christmas makes our Christmas Eve service,
makes it a little challenging.
We are going to have our Christmas Eve service on December the 21st,
which is a Sunday at 5.
So it's a regular church service.
And we will have a family friendly service with carols and candle lighting.
So please mark your calendars to join us for our Christmas Eve service.
If you are interested in learning more about what baptism means,
we will have information classes on December 7th and 14th before service.
The baptism service will be held on Sunday, January the 11th.
Please RSVP by scanning the QR code.
December 28th, which is the Sunday right after Christmas,
we will not be having service in order to give our volunteers a break in family time.
We will see you the following Sunday for Story Sunday on January the 4th.
If you are anxious about being in a church setting,
or you're just part of a disability community,
or just feeling fidgety today,
we have an accessibility bucket right over there that you are welcome to.
There's fidget devices, there's coloring sheets,
and there's noise canceling earplugs.
So you may pick it up if you'd like,
and then please return it on your way out.
These candles are a sign of the presence of Christ among us,
fully divine and fully human.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry, and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence, stillness, and grace.
Now we enter sacred space.
A space for prayer, worship, and adoration.
A space to encounter Christ, revelation of God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thanks, Kat.
If you guys want to stand with us, our worship today,
I gotta be honest, I really wish this piano bench was a little bit longer,
because my comfort zone is to sit right beside my sister at our home on our piano,
and to play and sing music together, and that is how we prepared this set.
And if there was enough space for both of our butts on this bench,
that is where I would be.
And we would be watching this sheet music,
and you guys would all be on couches, or in sweats, you know.
That is what I'm envisioning in my head,
just this idea of sinking in to the comfort and the love of God tonight.
So I hope that you guys can join us there.
Imagine your favorite place at your house,
or maybe somewhere else that you feel at home,
and put yourself into that kind of mindset tonight as we worship together,
because wherever you feel most at home, wherever you are most yourself,
God's love is so good, and he sees us there, and he wants that for us.
He wants us to come home to ourselves, to the people he made us to be.
So I hope that we can all kind of enter that space together tonight.
Wrong song. That's not the song.
But that also does feel very much at home right there.
That's something that we would have done and probably did earlier today.
First is going to be Dave for singing, all right?
♪♪♪
♪ Mercy rising with the rising of the sun ♪
♪ Goodness rationing and filling up my lungs ♪
♪ Your faithfulness is here and now, the evidence is all around ♪
♪ I bless your name, I give you praise, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ Awake my soul, come on and praise the Lord, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ Oh my soul, praise the Lord, oh my soul, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ A new song, it's welling up from deep inside of me, new life, hallelujah, I have been redeemed ♪
♪ I have been redeemed, I bless your name, I give you praise, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ Awake my soul, come on and praise the Lord, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ Oh my soul, praise the Lord, oh my soul, today is the day for singing, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ From the valley to the mountain, the desert to the fountain, oh I will praise you ♪
♪ From the morning to the evening, as long as I am breathing, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ Today is the day for singing, today, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ I bless your name, I give you praise, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ Awake my soul, come on and praise the Lord, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ And oh my soul, praise the Lord, oh my soul, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ Today is the day for singing, from the mountain to the valley, the desert to the fountain, oh I will praise you ♪
♪ From the morning to the evening, as long as I am breathing, today is the day for singing ♪
♪ Today is the day for singing, today, today is the day for singing ♪
Alright, you kids are dismissed to go to your classes and your teachers will meet you over by the doors.
And we are going to move into something that we call Prayers of the People.
Um, you can follow along on the screens, the parts in red we will read aloud together.
Jesus, for this city of Sachse, Texas, and for every city and community and all who live in them, we pray to you.
For the good earth you have given us and the wisdom and the will to conserve it, we pray to you.
For the old and the sick, for the widow and the orphan, for the injured and suffering, we pray to you.
For the poor and the oppressed, the unemployed and destitute, for prisoners and captives and all who remember and care for them, we pray to you.
For the vulnerable, the marginalized, and those unjustly targeted for their gender, sexuality, race, or other perceived difference, we pray to you.
For those experiencing loss, loneliness, and disconnection, and for those struggling with mental and emotional health, we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us and that you hear us, so we lift these names and situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we have spoken aloud and for those that we have kept in our hearts, we pray to you that they may have life and light, healing and hope, peace, and a deep sense of your presence. Amen.
You broke my chains of sin and shame, and you covered me in your love.
You broke my chains of sin and shame, and you covered me with grace.
You mend my life with your holy fire, you cover me with grace.
You are the hand that reaches out to save, I am set free, oh, I am set free, oh, it is for freedom that I am set free.
You broke my chains of sin and shame, and you covered me with grace.
You mend my life with your holy fire, you cover me with grace.
You are the hand that reaches out to save, I am set free, oh, I am set free, oh, it is for freedom that I am set free.
I am set free, oh, I am set free, oh, it is for freedom that I am set free.
Yes, Lord, we are grateful for your grace and for your love.
You are the hand that reaches out to save, because your glory is so beautiful.
I fall onto my knees in awe, and the heartbeat of my life is to worship in your light.
Your glory is so beautiful.
My life is yours.
My hope is in you only.
My heart you hold, because you made this sinner holy and holy, holy.
Because your glory is so beautiful.
I fall onto my knees in awe, and the heartbeat of my life is to worship in your light.
Your glory is so beautiful.
Glory, glory, hallelujah, Jesus, you are good.
We sing glory, glory, hallelujah, Jesus, you are good.
I am set free.
It is for freedom that I am set free.
It is so sweet to trust in Jesus, just to take Him at His word,
just to rest upon His promise and to know the Savior Lord.
It is so sweet to trust in Jesus, just from sin and self to cease,
just from Jesus simply taking life and rest and joy and peace.
Jesus, Jesus, how I trust Him, how I prove Him o'er and o'er.
Jesus, Jesus, precious Jesus, oh, for grace to trust Him more.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yes, Lord, we are grateful for Your grace and for Your love.
Because You are the hand that reaches out to save.
And I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
It is for freedom that I am set free.
In Romans 6 it says,
So since we're out from under the old tyranny, does that mean we can live any old way that we want?
Since we're free in the freedom of God, can we just do anything that comes to mind?
Hardly. You know well enough from your own experience that there are some acts of so-called freedom that destroy freedom.
Offer yourselves to sin, for instance, and it's the last free act.
But offer yourselves to the ways of God, and that freedom never quits.
All your life you've let sin tell you what to do, but thank God you've started listening to a new master.
One whose commands set you free to live openly in His freedom.
You can readily recall, can't you, how at one time the more you did just whatever you felt like doing, not caring about others, not caring about God,
the worse your life became and the less freedom you had.
And how much different is it now as you live in God's freedom, your life healed and expansive in holiness.
God, I'm so grateful that your ways lead us towards more freedom.
Towards more of ourselves being at home in who you created us to be.
God, thank you that holiness does not look like shame.
But holiness looks like renewal.
Holiness looks like hope.
Something better.
Something wrapped in your love.
In your beauty.
In your wholeness.
I love the words of that old hymn that says,
Just from Jesus simply taking His life, His rest, His joy, His peace.
God, would we live into that space?
Would we take your life on?
Would we take on your peace?
Your rest?
Would we let go of shame and condemnation and trying to measure up?
Proving, controlling, manipulating.
Would those things fall by the wayside as we pursue a God who is about freeing us?
Would we come to know that kind of love in you?
It's in your name I pray all these things tonight.
Thank you for this time together.
Amen.
Would you guys be seated and as you do turn to the people beside you and say the peace of Christ be with you.
The word that Isaiah son of Amos saw concerning Judah and Jerusalem.
In days to come the mountain of the Lord's house shall be established as the highest of the mountains.
And shall be raised above the hills.
All the nations shall stream to it.
Many people shall come and say come let us go up to the mountain of the Lord to the house of the God of Jacob.
That He may teach us His ways.
And that we may walk in His paths.
For out of Zion shall go forth instruction and the word of the Lord from Jerusalem.
He shall judge between the nations and shall arbitrate for many peoples.
They shall beat their swords into plowshares and their spears into pruning hooks.
Nations shall not lift up sword against nation.
Neither shall they learn war anymore.
O house of Jacob come let us walk in the light of the Lord.
Good evening friends.
My name is Charles if you don't know me.
My pronouns are he him.
Welcome friends who are in the room and also who are joining us online.
I'm glad you're here today.
I hope you were able to enjoy some time to rest.
To eat some good food.
To spend time with people that you love.
I for one was grateful that my oldest was home from college for the week and is now headed back.
I mean I love the rest of my family.
I just get to see them more than I get to see Ryan right now.
So I'm coming in grateful for that.
Today marks the first Sunday in Advent in the Christian calendar.
And Advent is the first season of the Christian calendar.
So Happy New Year I guess.
Happy Christian New Year.
The word Advent means arrival.
The season of Advent refers to two arrivals.
It refers to the initial arrival of Jesus the Messiah.
His birth in Bethlehem.
The entrance of God in human form in the world.
The second arrival is the arrival that hasn't happened yet.
When Jesus arrives again to make all things new.
The season of Advent is this sense of anticipation and waiting and hope in these new arrivals.
In the season of waiting.
The season of Christmas marks the actual birth of Jesus.
The season of Advent is about the anticipation of Jesus' arrival in the world simultaneously.
It's about the anticipation of Jesus' second arrival.
The second coming to heal and renew the entire cosmos including us.
We're following the lectionary for our messages this Advent.
If you're not familiar with the lectionary it's a list of texts for each week of the Christian calendar that follows a three year cycle.
Over the course of three years you kind of hit all of the major highlights of the scriptures.
If you're curious to learn more about that we don't follow the lectionary all the time.
You can Google revised common lectionary and Vanderbilt's website will come up.
You can just see all the things that we see when we look at the so-called lectionary.
Each week has a reading from the Hebrew Bible or the Old Testament.
Another one specifically from the Psalms.
A New Testament reading and a reading specifically from one of the Gospels in the New Testament.
And that text I read from Isaiah is the Hebrew Bible reading for this week.
I'll be honest.
When I read through the texts for this week I didn't at first feel encouragement or hope or strength.
Instead I felt dissonance.
I had coffee with a good friend after reading through them one time and they asked how are you doing?
And I said I'm kind of cranky.
Why are you cranky?
I've been reading the Bible which may sound strange but also may be a point of growth for me in my middle age.
I grew up revering the Bible.
The Bible was untouchable.
It was uncriticable and as a result I felt this pressure to always be positively inclined toward Scripture.
To assume that any questions I had about it was automatically my own ignorance or my stubbornness or my short-sightedness and I have plenty of those.
But in my middle age also I'm allowing for the possibility that the Bible could provoke some crankiness in me.
To be frustrated.
With the Bible.
To have questions of it.
To be honest about it with God when it's just not doing it for me.
And that was the case this week.
I read these texts and they just weren't doing it for me.
I felt all kinds of dissonance.
Which might be surprising given the vision of Isaiah 2.
This beautiful heart capturing picture of God's peace and justice filling the world.
Everyone in union with God and with each other.
Repurposing tools of war for tools of creation and cultivation and flourishing.
What a beautiful vision.
And yet I feel dissonance when I consider that here we are some 2700 years removed from this text.
And that vision feels just as far away in the future as it must have in Isaiah's day.
The current administration has renamed the Department of Defense the Department of War.
Speaking of war, there are so many currently underway in Ukraine and in Palestine and in several other places.
We appear to be no more closer to shalom and peace today than in Isaiah's time.
When Israel was complicit with injustice and violence against the least powerful and the most vulnerable.
So I read the second text.
Psalm 122.
Hoping perhaps to preach from a text that felt less dissonant.
Verses 6 through 9 read.
Pray for the peace of Jerusalem.
May they prosper who love you.
Peace be within your walls and security within your towers.
For the sake of my relatives and friends I will say peace be within you.
For the sake of the house of the Lord our God I will seek your good.
What a beautiful prayer.
And yet I read this and I couldn't help but to think of the way that peace is not in fact within Jerusalem's walls and towers today.
Jerusalem has been in its latest conflict for more than a year now.
Beginning more than a year ago from an assault from Hamas in October of 2024.
But what causes me more dissonance is to wonder how to pray for the peace of Jerusalem.
When Israel has itself become a perpetrator of great violence and death against so many Palestinians in Gaza.
I want to pray for peace and for the good of Gaza who Israel would consider an enemy.
More dissonance.
I turn next to the New Testament text from Romans 13.
In verses 11 and 12 the Apostle Paul writes salvation is nearer to us than when we became believers first.
The night is far gone.
The day is near.
Is it really Paul?
The night is far gone?
Did that really come true?
With all that's going on in the world some 2,000 years later with the violence against undocumented immigrants.
With the scapegoating and unjust treatment of our transgender siblings.
With all the war and atrocity that we've already mentioned.
It feels like we are in the dead of night bro.
Surely Jesus has something helpful to say.
The Gospel text is from Matthew 24.
Where Jesus talks about what some interpret as the rapture.
Two will be in the field one will be taken the other left.
Two women will be grinding meal together one will be taken the other left.
I am so glad that Brett solved all the problems of the rapture in the eschatology series this fall.
So I can just move right past that to Jesus punchline.
Where he says you don't know when the Lord is coming.
So stay awake.
Be alert. Be ready.
The Son of Man is coming at an hour you don't expect.
I don't know about you.
But this text brings all my hell trauma right to the surface.
Be ready or else Jesus will get you.
Don't misbehave because Jesus might return right in the middle of it.
I can hear that old Gospel preacher.
Stoking fear to get folks to comply and obey with the church's moral norms.
I mean the Son of Man is even compared to a thief who comes in the middle of the night to rob someone.
Stay awake so you don't get robbed.
That's not a heartwarming image.
More dissonance.
Sorry to be such a downer y'all.
Maybe, just maybe you feel some of this dissonance yourself.
The dissonance between the world we currently live in and the world that is promised to arrive one day.
It seems better to be honest about the dissonance than to try to spiritually bypass it.
Or to sugar coat it.
Or ignore it.
This dissonance is exactly where I long for God to meet me.
To meet us in this Advent season.
What would it look like for God to meet us in the midst of this dissonance?
To hold this dissonance with us.
To lead us through it instead of around it.
That's exactly what I wondered as I sat with these texts.
God, what do we do with this?
What's your invitation to us in the midst of dissonance like this?
What does it look like for us to faithfully anticipate your arrival in this Advent season?
I'll admit that I came to these texts with some ideas about what we might do with the dissonance.
Instead of avoiding it, to move through it.
To let God sit with us in it.
To lament the dissonance to God.
To share our frustration and confusion and even anger with God.
Lament after all is a very common response to dissonance in the Psalms.
And certainly I commend lament as a healing practice.
But as I read through the texts again and again, I began to notice something else.
That addressed this dissonance.
That gave me something to hold on to.
Jesus mentions it in Matthew 24 when he says, keep awake.
Be ready.
Paul mentions it in Romans 13 when he says, let us walk decently as in the day.
Put on the Lord Jesus Christ.
And what do you know, there it is at the end of our Isaiah text.
Oh house of Jacob, come.
Let us walk in the light of the Lord.
What I hear Jesus and Paul and Isaiah saying is that one way we can respond to this dissonance is with our lives.
By embodying here and now in the midst of the dumpster fire of things.
The future peace and goodness and justice for which we long.
That's what Isaiah means when he invites Israel to walk in the light of the Lord.
To walk in the ways of God.
To embody in the present the peace and justice that is coming more fully in the future.
When all will stream to the mountain of God and be instructed in God's ways.
When humanity will repurpose its war weapons into creation tools.
What if walking in the light of the Lord means that we go ahead and start living the future now?
What if the most faithful form of waiting is practicing the good way of Jesus right now?
To put on the Lord Jesus Christ as Paul says.
The vibe of this invitation is not that it's all up to us.
As if God's not going to do it and so we've got to create a different world on our own kind of thing.
What if God is already doing it?
What if God has always been doing it?
What if God's at work to heal and renew and restore and our invitation is to participate in it?
Isaiah's invitation after all is to walk by the light of the Lord.
We don't have to generate the light.
The light doesn't begin with us.
We just have to find it and walk in it.
Neither is the vibe of this invitation to walk in the light of the Lord or else.
Thanks be to God. Contrary to my anxieties.
Or else God will get us or else God will judge us and send us to hell.
It's more like the plea of someone who loves us all so dearly.
Please, please walk in the light.
Because the fruit of walking in the light is light.
And the fruit of walking in darkness is darkness.
What fruit do we want?
God doesn't coerce or threaten us.
The plea comes to us as an invitation to participate.
To join in what the Spirit of God is doing.
What the Spirit of God is doing to clothe ourselves with the character and action of Jesus.
This invitation reminds me of something I've heard my co-director in the Healing Collective, Mallory Wykoff, say.
That the best critique of the bad is the embodiment of the better.
The best critique of the bad is the embodiment of the better.
I love that.
I feel like it's a place that I can put my dissonant energy.
Instead of getting stuck in the dissonance, paralyzed by it.
What if that was the energy that fueled me, that fueled us to embody the better?
The best critique of war is the embodiment of peace.
The best critique of scarcity is the embodiment of provision.
The best critique of loneliness is the embodiment of belonging.
The best critique of polarization is the embodiment of proximity.
The best critique of apathy is the embodiment of empathy.
The best critique of dehumanization is the embodiment of kindness.
The best critique of injustice is the embodiment of love.
A couple weeks ago, I accepted an invitation from my friend and colleague, Colin Packer,
to join him and another friend of ours, David Park,
at the Dallas Field Office of Immigration and Customs Enforcement, also known as ICE.
Colin had been invited by a grassroots organization called Vicinos Unidos DFW,
led by several Chicana women,
who are showing up every day at the field office to help migrant folks know their rights
and to raise awareness about the mistreatment of our undocumented neighbors by ICE.
Colin and David and I were there, and we were invited specifically because we are white clergypersons.
Unfortunately, and not surprisingly, ICE agents respond much differently to white male clergymembers
than they do to our brown female colleagues.
They yell and curse and make threats to brown women,
but when a white clergyperson is present, they are respectful and calm.
So our invitation was to show up and share the privilege that comes with our being white
to our non-white colleagues so that they could do their work more safely, more effectively.
The leaders of Vicinos Unidos asked us to find some way to identify ourselves as clergy
with either a stole or a collar, and that's why I'm wearing this tonight.
Both so that ICE would know that we were clergy,
but also so that our neighbors would not wonder if we were casual ICE agents ourselves
and become suspicious of Vicinos Unidos and their work there.
And so we borrowed three stoles, one of which I'm wearing from our dear friend and colleague,
Pepa Paniagua, who some of you know.
She's a Presbyterian minister, and she's got stoles and spades, apparently.
It's the first time I've ever worn one. This is the second time I've ever worn one.
It feels a little weird, honestly, but isn't it pretty? It's so beautiful, yeah?
So one Friday, a couple weeks ago, we arrived a little bit before 6 a.m. in our stoles.
We met the team. We stood on the sidewalk outside the field office,
ready to help however we were needed, but mostly just to stand there.
Occasionally, cars would come toward us down this industrial West Dallas street,
and if the cars were moving fast and sometimes blaring music,
they were probably ICE agents checking in for their shift.
I noticed in big letters on the back of one truck entering the employee parking lot,
Jesus saves.
I could feel the tension and anger in my body as those cars raced by,
many without license plates, so that they couldn't be identified.
I noticed as I looked over that my friend and colleague David
was waving at the ICE agents as they came in, and that humanized them for me.
I was like, oh, I needed that. I felt the difference, the opposition there,
and some would see the stoles, and they would wave back at us.
Oh, something felt shifted.
We wondered if they were worried about their own families.
We wondered if their families were worried about them.
If the cars were moving slowly down the street,
they were usually our neighbors showing up for their immigration check-in appointments.
Our colleagues would wave down the slow-moving cars and invite them to talk,
and if they were willing, they would pull into an adjacent parking lot
where our colleagues would let them know that ICE was detaining high numbers of people
showing up for their routine immigration check-ins.
They encouraged them to sign a form that would allow Vicinos Unidos
to contact their family, to be able to track them in the system.
Otherwise, there'd be no way to know where they went, where they were,
what their status was.
Detainees are sometimes transferred out of state on purpose
to make it difficult to impede their deportation process.
Our colleagues also encouraged them to park in the adjacent lot
and not in the ICE parking lot because ICE has contracts with local towing companies
to impound cars that stay in their lot.
If they came with family members, our colleagues encouraged their family members to leave
because ICE agents would often ask,
do you have family waiting for you?
And if they do, it's not uncommon for ICE to go out in the parking lot
and detain the family members as well.
Occasionally, we were asked to pray for our neighbors
who were walking to the field office for their appointments,
and we prayed for peace and protection as they trembled.
Sometimes clergy members were asked to escort our colleagues and neighbors
to the door of the field office to inquire about their family members
who had been inside for longer than expected and might be detained.
I watched as one pregnant woman came back with her small child
and returned from asking about her husband.
She wept as she learned that he had been detained.
Our colleagues gave her a place to sit and food to eat.
They played with her son as she processed the news that she had just received.
I listened as David asked Noemi, one of the founders of Vicinos Unidos DFW,
how she came into this work.
And with tears in her eyes, she shared how her own father
had been deported when she was young.
She knows what it's like, and she wants to help other people
who are in similar circumstances.
And so she gets up every day early to come to the field office
to help her neighbors before she goes in to her full-time job.
Noemi might not use this language, but she and her colleagues
are walking in the light of the Lord.
In the midst of the dissonance of detention and mass deportation
and mistreatment of undocumented neighbors,
in the midst of injustice, they accepted the invitation
to participate in God's peace and justice and goodness.
To critique the bad by embodying the better.
To anticipate with their active bodies the renewed and healed world
that is to come.
The world we hope for in the second coming of the Christ
in this Advent season.
I wonder, how might the Spirit be inviting you
to walk in the light of the Lord this Advent?
To embody the goodness of God.
Where do you long for more peace and goodness and justice
and belonging around you?
What opportunities to embody those longings
is the Spirit sending your way?
We don't have to fabricate the opportunities.
We simply have to pay attention for what the Spirit
might be sending toward us and cooperate with it.
Go with the flow of it.
And if it seems daunting, I hear you.
There's some risk in accepting such an invitation.
I am usually pretty anxious to accept the invitation myself.
So it's normal. You're in good company.
And I hope you'll be kind to yourself
in the midst of the dauntingness of it.
The good news is that the invitation is to us collectively.
Let us walk in the light of the Lord.
This embodiment work is something we get to do together.
Something I got to do with my brothers, Colin and David.
If we long for peace in our world, let us be a community of peace.
If we long for belonging in our world,
let us be a community of belonging.
If we long for the recognition of the image of God in all of humanity,
let us be a community that recognizes the image of God in each other.
If we long for generosity in our world,
let us be a community of generosity.
If we long for justice in our world,
let us be a community of justice.
Come, let us walk in the light of the Lord.
In the name of the Father, and of the Son, and the Holy Spirit. Amen.
It is time for communion.
At the table we practice open communion.
So all are welcome to participate who wish to.
We go row by row from the front to the back to this center aisle all the way up
to receive the bread and the cup.
As you take the cup, just know that the red is wine and the white is juice.
And you are welcome to spend some time in prayer or kneeling up here at the front
or to return to your seat, whatever is most comfortable and preferable to you.
This is the table, not of the church, but of the Lord.
It's made ready for those who love Him and for those who want to love Him more.
So come, you who have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who have not been here long.
You who have tried to follow and you who have failed.
Come, because it is the Lord who invites you.
It's His will that those who want Him should meet Him here.
Come to the table.
Come.
Tonight we're going to end with a prayer.
I know it might be new for some of you as we've only done it once or twice here, but
if you guys would stand with us in this prayer and just receive this as you go into your
week and let it lead us into that freedom, that hope for what is to come, that embodiment
of walking in the light of Christ.
Would you take, Lord, and receive my liberty, my memory, my understanding, and my will,
all that I call my own?
Give me only your loving grace, your loving grace.
That is enough.
That is enough for me.
You have given all to me.
To you, Lord, I return it.
Everything belongs to you.
Do with it what you will.
Give me only your loving grace, your loving grace.
That is enough.
That is enough for me.
For me.
Thank you so much for joining us this evening.
Thank you, Charles, for that wonderful message.
If you are new, we would love for you to fill out a card at the table or an online
visitor card by scanning the QR code.
Just to let you know, we could reach out and let you know that we're glad that you joined
us.
Generosity is a key aspect of life, of adoration and worship.
To give financially, you can scan the QR code or visit the table at thetabletx.org.
If you call the table home but don't currently have a meetup, you may go into the table,
tx.org, and there are several meetups that you can choose from and find one that fits
your schedule and your time and have a meetup with the different folks in the community.
Also, if you are not part of a ministry team and you are interested in that, we have several
ministries that, if that's something that sounds like you would like to do, there's
the host team and the AV team and also our praise team and our kids ministry.
So, you can find something that works for you.
Alright, let me send you out with this benediction.
You may hold your hand down in a posture to receive or just open your hearts to these
words.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and this is true on your worst day.
So, as you go into your week ahead with its yet to be determined highs and lows and everything
in between, go filled with the assurance that you are loved, that you are worthy, and that
you are accepted just as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to extend these same gifts of grace
and unconditional love to everyone you come in contact with.
Be blessed.
Have a great week and we'll see you again next Sunday.
Give me only your love and grace.
That is enough.
For me.